es gibt eine ganze menge gemüse die man
im september noch serien und pflanzen
kann vielleicht ist jetzt in deinen
beten wieder platz geworden an den
stellen wo wir schon alles aufgegessen
hast dann kannst du dir jetzt noch mal
deine saatgut tütchen packen und
nachsehen und nach pflanzen das ist
natürlich toll wenn man dann im winter
und im frühling auch mehr ernten kann so
kannst du viel mehr ernte aus den beeten
rausholen und das ist auch für den boden
viel besser wenn da den winter über
pflanzen draufstehen als wenn er nackt
da legt deswegen fangen wir gleich an
mit den gemüsen die man im september
aussehen oder pflanzen kann wenn du lust
hast noch ein paar gemüse im haus
vorzuziehen habe ich da drei kandidaten
für dich mit denen das jetzt noch
wunderbar klappt einmal mangold einmal
spinat salat salat dass es so ein
bisschen so eine sache es gibt so hatten
die sehr viel winterharte sind als
andere
ich baue ganz gerne die sorte partie an
aber die ist ganz oft ausverkauft und
deswegen habe ich dieses jahr eine
andere sorte die ich auch noch
ausprobieren möchte mit der das
anscheinend auch wunderbar funktioniert
das ist die winter marie und soweit ich
das recherchiert habe gibt es davon auf
jeden fall noch saatgut zu kaufen das
war ja so ärgerlich für viele von euch
dass der akku schnell ausverkauft war
beim spinat war ich am liebsten die
sorte linter riesen an in den kalten
monaten im sommer habe ich die sorte
gamma sonne im anbau weil die
schlossfeste ist das heißt sie geht
nicht so schnell in die blüte im winter
ist es dann aber besser auf eine sorte
zu setzen die fröste auch gut wegsteckt
und bei mangold da habe ich eigentlich
keine spezifischen unterschiede
feststellen können
ich mache gern so einen mix an rainbow
heißt er hat man dann pinke orangene
gelbe weiße rote und so weiter mangold
stille das ist dann irgendwie besonders
hübsch aber ich habe auch mit anderen
sorten super erfahrungen gemacht die
kannst du jetzt also im haus vorziehen
die kannst du aber alle auch direkt im
speziellen ins beet kannst du aber auch
noch einige gemüse mehr sehen damit
machen wir jetzt mal weiter das wären
zum beispiel die postel ein ich weiß
nicht ob du kennst das ist so ein ganz
lockerer milder sehr gesunder salat der
wunderbar in den kalten monaten wächst
die man den ganzen winter über ernten
kann bei dem postel 1 ist es besonders
wichtig dass man darauf achtet dass es
bei der aussaat relativ kühl ist weil
der erst kommt wenn es unter 15 grad
kalt ist es nicht so kalt aber im
september ist
ist ja oft zu warm kann man aber auch im
oktober noch aussehen wenn jetzt die
temperaturen vielleicht noch ein
bisschen zu hoch sind da immer darauf
achten denn wenn es wärmer ist dann
gehen die nicht so gut auf oder keime
überhaupt nicht dann kann man jetzt auch
wunderbar feldsalat sehen ist jetzt die
beste zeit um das anzugehen ich war oder
ganz gern eine sorte an die ich mir
nicht merken kann ich blende euch den
namen hier und nach in das ist meine
lieblingssorte irgendwas französisches
mit wert ihr werdet das dann hier unten
lesen das ist eine sorte die ich euch
sehr für den winter an wir empfehlen
kann dann ist auch asia salat was super
leckeres alter salate sind super
forsthart sehr lecker oft ein bisschen
scharf aber da gibt es auch
unterschiedliche sorten ich kann euch
mal ein paar sorten einblenden die ich
super gerne an bord wenn ihr noch platz
haben dann probiert das auf jeden fall
aus das ist super super lecker im
wintergarten salate mit einem asia salat
aufzupeppen der noch ein bisschen mehr
geschmack reinbringt echt ne tolle sache
und wie gesagt spinat salat und mangold
könnt ihr auch direkt im speed sehen wie
könnt ihr sowohl im haus vorziehen wenn
ihr jetzt vielleicht noch keinen platz
in den beeten habt der aber bald frei
werden wird als auch direkt ins beet
sehen weil salat ist es oft ein bisschen
einfacher den im haus vorzuziehen weil
man da die erde besser feucht halten
kann salat ist ja ein licht kaymer das
heißt er streut man die samen nur
oberflächlich auf die erde auf und das
ist manchmal im september noch ein
bisschen schwierig wenn es draußen so
heiß ist dass man die erde dann draußen
im beet gleichmäßig feucht hält ich bin
ja immer ein freund vom direkt ins beet
sehen weil die pflanzen dann tiefere
wurzeln systeme entwickeln was aber im
winter gar nicht so entscheidend ist
hier im sommer aber falls euch das
interessiert in dem video da oben habe
ich darüber noch viel mehr erzählt da
geht es nämlich darum wie man möglichst
viel wasser sparen kann im garten und
komplett ohne gießen oder fast ohne
gießen auskommt ansonsten habe ich auch
ganz gute erfahrungen gemacht jetzt noch
eine späte aussaat zu machen da kommt es
aber wieder ganz arg auf die sorte an
ich baue so spät im jahr am liebsten die
sorte gonsenheimer treibt an das ist
eine sehr kurze sehr schnell wachsende
möhre die ja für diese randzeiten im
jahr gut geeignet ist also sehr früh im
jahr oder
sehr spät im jahr die werden natürlich
dann nicht riesig also man ernte dann
auch nur kleine möhren die kann man aber
den winter über im beet stehen lassen
wenn man die gut mit mulch abdeckt oder
mit einem vlies ist das kein problem und
kann die dann nach bedarf den winter
über erntens finde ich eine super sache
das sind dann so kleine snack hören das
geht jetzt auf jeden fall auch noch und
dann auch noch eine sache wo ja anfang
september kann man das schon noch machen
und zwar dicke bohnen sehen viele sehr
in ihre dicken bohnen ja erst im
frühjahr
aber ich habe die erfahrung gemacht wie
man die jetzt zählt und die dann schon
auf gehen vor dem winter und dem beet
überwintern die sind ziemlich frost hat
da müsst ihr euch nicht viele sorgen um
die machen das die irgendwie erfrieren
könnten dass sie dann im nächsten jahr
weniger anfällig für die schwarze
bodenlos sind die schwarze bohnen aus
befällt dicke boni zu haus und die
bohnen die man im bett überwintern lässt
die sind da irgendwie widerstandsfähiger
also das könnt ihr auf jeden fall mal
ausprobieren wenn ihr für die gewonnene
platz im bild habt dann seht ihr jetzt
schon klappt bei uns auf jeden fall viel
besser als wenn wir die im frühling sein
und jetzt wird auch langsam zeit
knoblauch zu stecken und winterspeck
zwiebeln winter zwiebeln sind auch
zwiebeln die im beet überwintern
das heißt man steckt die jetzt im herbst
im september oder oktober wenn die schon
ein bisschen auf überwintern im beet und
nächstes jahr dann frühe ernte bereit
dafür sind die nicht so gut lagerfähig
meistens deswegen bauen wir dann auch im
frühling noch sorten an die wieder
anlagern können aber damit wir früher im
jahr ernten können und auch im winter
immer das zwiebel grün ernten können
bauen wir jedes jahr winter steckt
zwiebeln an ist das eine super coole
sache ich mag die sorte elektra ganz
gerne die gibt es leider nicht in
bioqualität zumindest habe ich die
nirgendwo gefunden
aber ich kann euch wenn wenn ich noch
andere winter zwiebel sorten finde die
in bio qualität erhältlich sind kann ich
die euch gerne noch mal hier unten
einblenden bei knoblauch ist das auch so
eine sache den pflanzt sich auch sehr
viel lieber im herbst dazu kommt auch
bald noch ein video also im ist sei es
auch noch nicht unbedingt jetzt loslegen
ihr habt noch bis oktober zeit wenn ihr
knoblauch pflanzen wollt aber das ist
finde ich sehr viel besser als wenn man
den erst im frühjahr
steckt weil die knollen sehr viel dicker
werden wenn sie diesen vorsprung haben
jetzt um ihr habt noch einmal wachsen
können den winter über im beet stehen
und dann bis nächsten juli richtig schön
dicke knollen willen kann also die im
herbst gesteckten werden bei uns viel
viel dicker als die im frühling also
wenn ihr knoblauch anbauen wolltest das
jetzt auch nur super zeit dafür aber wie
gesagt da werde ich euch noch mal genau
zeigen wie das geht in einem der
nächsten videos ja und für diejenigen
von euch die einen freeway kasten oder
ein gewächshaus haben
da gelten natürlich auch alle kandidaten
die ich jetzt hier erwähnt habe aber ihr
habt noch ein paar mehr möglichkeiten
ihr könnt jetzt zum beispiel auch noch
rucola aussehen der ja wir machen das so
dass wir den einfach im bett stehen
lassen
der samen sich selber auch so dass wir
da jetzt überhaupt nichts zu tun haben
aber wenn noch cooler aus sein willst
dann geht es im frühbeet kasten oder
gewächshaus jetzt immer noch
dann kannst du radieschen aussehen im
frühbeet kasten oder gewächshaus das
funktioniert auch sehr gut wie ich die
erfahrung gemacht habe auch mit allen
sorten also da habe ich keine großen
unterschiede feststellen können was die
forst empfindlichkeit angeht aksoy
kannst du jetzt auch noch sehr in den
geschützten anbau das ist ja auch ein
asiatisches gemüse das sehr sehr
frosthart ist gartenkresse funktioniert
jetzt auch noch im bettkasten und auch
im gewächshaus und was war das letzte
partie der serie ist auch sehr ja wenn
es richtig kalt wird friert die schon ab
aber im gewächshaus kann man die auf
jeden fall sehr gut überwintern
den ganzen winter über frische
petersilie grün ernten das ist auf jeden
fall auch eine tolle sache da könnt ihr
jetzt auch noch petersilie sehen oder
pflanzen vielleicht habe ich ja noch das
eine oder andere gemüse vergessen dann
lasst uns das gerne unten in den
kommentaren wissen ich freue mich auf
jeden fall immer von euch zu hören
wenn ihr mehr gartentipps wollt dann
abonniert gerne den kanal ich bin's die
hier jede woche immer samstags um 10 ein
neues video und um das thema
gemüsegarten und selbstversorgung aus
dem eigenen garten
ansonsten ist es natürlich auch super
schön wenn man nicht nur im winter
frisches gemüse aus dem garten erntet
sondern auch die sommergemüse die jetzt
reif sind für den winter haltbar macht
zum beispiel tomatensoße einfach oder
auch gemüse fermentiert da kann ich euch
gerne mal hier trieben eine playlist
verlinken zum haltbarmachen der ernte da
findet ihr alle meine gesammelten tipps
und da unten findet ihr auch noch ein
video das euch interessieren könnte
ansonsten freue ich mich wenn wir uns
nächste woche wieder sehen das ganz toll
wenn man gerade recht ich muss noch mal
neu anfangen